the Kalahari Desert in central Botswana
is home to an indigenous group known as
the Sun making a fire requires not just
patients but also skilled hands and a
knowledge of local shrubs and other
plants tabatha Mesaba says this
centuries-old wisdom offers these rural
communities a unique opportunity in a
way we are now about to transition to
what we call the knowledge-based economy
and I think indigenous knowledge systems
because they really stem from knowledge
of people and people's hands and
handiwork can really help diversify the
economy of Botswana because currently we
are in need of people to really
enterprise and to make things for
themselves and turn them into businesses
that can really sustain them the Sun
have survived in this harsh environment
for centuries nowadays they struggle
with unemployment and poverty many young
people don't see a future here so
they've decided to look for work
elsewhere
Tabitha Machado believes the Sun have
much to offer modern society in
particular how to make the most of
meager resources he founded this
workshop in the village of Dakar with
the help of an American NGO design and
engineer students work with local
residents to develop machines and
products that can be used by small
businesses this is a makerspace which we
started basically around 2015 as a
concept and now it's an actual project
which the sand community in Dakar meet
on a day-to-day basis to either get
basic ICT skills or to use the power
tools and hand tools and materials that
we have in the workshop to make
themselves their appropriate
technologies that address the livelihood
challenges that they go through
today a group of American University
students is in the workshop together
with local residents
Shannon McCoy is working on a wheelchair
designed for rugged terrain
the invention aims to make elderly
people more mobile design is to help
make this wheelchair more workable on
sand so we added these chains and gears
to turn this into a hand cycle to
provide more power and we also doubled
the wheels to provide more traction and
surface area on the sand the wheelchair
is still in the prototype stage once the
design is finalized local craftsmen hope
to set up businesses to upgrade already
existing models that will help the
elderly and the economy instead of
seeing those that I at the bottom of a
pyramid as a charity case we should see
them as potential innovators and
potential entrepreneurs that if
supported well can actually take the
baton economy to the next level that is
LED and driven by knowledge as opposed
to by mineral dependency together with
the American NGO cabesa masiva
is planning to open more maker spaces in
other communities in Botswana